If you wanna know how to decide if a career opportunity is a good one,...
...there are several things you have to take into consideration.
Number 1: Does it make your heart sing?
The number one feedback system that you were given at birth is joy.
If you're not experiencing joy as you think about doing something and as you pursue doing it,...
...then it's off course for you.
You also wanna put your rational mind to work.
You want it to do some due diligence.
Ask other people who've gone down that road before.
What was it like?
What did they have to do?
What were some of the costs of that path?
What were some of the payoffs and the benefits,...
...and really get a sense of what it would be like to do that.
Sometimes, you can go and do an internship...
...or you can work for a friend in their restaurant just to see if you like it,...
...'cause often the fantasy doesn't match the reality.
And the other thing is to simply trust yourself.
You know deep inside what's true for you.
And if you'll take a few minutes and go inside, we call it meditation,...
...and just ask and sit with the question and see what kind of feelings come up.
Does this feel right?
So do all the rational research,...
...but then ultimately bring it back into your heart...
...and decide, "Does this feel good for me?"
And if it makes sense up here and it feels good, then step into it.
Just lean into it and see what happens.
Pursue it.
No decision is forever.
You can always change if it's not what you want.